definitely think it's important as a
band when you first come together to
kind of sit down the group and say
what is Imagine Dragons what do we want
our image to be what are what is our
message
um what music should we all be listening
to collectively so you know what album
did you just pick up oh let me pick it
up too you know so we all come to kind
of an understanding of this is what
Imagine Dragons is and then you know and
then things shape it on their own as you
go but I think I do think it's really
important just like you know when you're
writing a paper thesis you know it's you
have to have some starting point and
move forward
Las Vegas is Imagine Dragons home the
energy the Larger than Life mentality
that we have that we bring to every
performance is Las Vegas personified and
it would not be that way if we had grown
up as a band in any other City the band
was absolutely born in Las Vegas and the
Las Vegas Strip is what
the petri dish that let the band life uh
grow and evolve into what it is today
yeah it was a great place to start I
don't think our band would have been
anything like what it is if we hadn't
been in any other city but Las Vegas you
know it's this eccentric big city with
lots of lights and it's theatrical it's
and that's really what the band is like
I love the drama I love the eccentricity
I love over the top I love that
Dan was born and raised there and he
always believed in the city you know
he's the one that sold us on the city
he's the one that said guys trust me
like I think we can really do something
here in Las Vegas our goal was to be a
self-sustained Indie band that could
like make enough money to pay rent and
have food right like no idea that it
would be what it is you can't ever
predict that it's one in a billion
foreign
[Music]